kubicki wenn wir uns das anschauen der
druck der da jetzt ausgeübt wird hier
haben wir noch mal die schlagzeile der
bild am sonntag von heute nämlich genau
zu dem thema wo es um die impfpflicht
für und nicht die impfpflicht das impfen
für zwölfjährige angeht und das was
morgen passiert herr kubicki wenn sie
sich das anschauen ist dass am ende was
gerade diskutiert wird eine impfpflicht
durch die hintertür
naja allein allein der druck die
aufgebaut wird dass menschen die nicht
geimpft sind am normalen
gesellschaftlichen leben nicht
teilnehmen können ist schon eine
drohkulisse die viele beeindrucken wird
und ich sage noch einmal das ist ja
wahrscheinlich der sinn der
veranstaltung war versprochen dass
gesetzlich nicht vorzuschreiben dass
sich jeder impfen lassen muss und
deshalb wird der soziale druck erhöht
und es sollte alles fertig erklärt auch
die tests werden künftig lieber nicht
mehr bezahlt wobei ich das ziemlich
komisch finde weil die impfung die auch
bezahlt wird also ist eben gesagt so
viele männer sie gar nicht es ist
nämlich durch die hintertür
selbstverständlich na ja so sehe ich es
nicht also es ist medizinisch
fachschlichtung und ideologisch
begründet also ich kann halt die ich
kann halt medizinische und ideologisch
in einem innenraum beispielsweise wenn
also die fahrzeuge kann ich den also
nicht games nicht so war
aber was ist was ist davon übrigen am 7
das dass die politik oder die regierung
an der die spd beteiligt ist den
deutschen versprochen hat dass es keine
impfpflicht geben wird und wenn man sich
die diskussion anschaut dieses vor einem
jahr zum beispiel gehabt genau zu dem
thema dann hat sich das doch sehr
verändert wir hören auch was der
kretschmann in baden-württemberg gesagt
hat wir hören was markus söder sagt was
mitglieder der bundesregierung sagen
alle machen druck auf die menschen dass
sich impfen soll das wenn ich also an
die menschen die nicht geimpft sind
appelliere bitte ist das anderes
abzusagen so dürfen dann machen wir das
restaurant zum beispiel ja aber das was
nicht es ist doch ganz klar will ich
dann
da vorgehen wenn wir wenn jetzt der
herbst kommt wir können nicht mehr
draußen setzen kleines restaurant ich
habe gestern abend meine tochter so in
einem italiener draußen gesessen
wenn jetzt die leute da draußen das
finale in den innenraum sind wirst doch
ganz klar in da also mit einer schnauze
es beispielsweise getestet werden wenn
da 32 leute drin sind also die positiv
sind und wo der schnelltest also
entweder fans negativ ist oder ist gar
nicht richtig gemacht worden war nur
dass die ersten zwei millimeter der nase
also benutzt worden sind
wir bieten die leute gefährten uns doch
alle dass das will doch niemand ich will
das auch nicht ich will nicht dass ich
wenig gefährdet werden also mit
durchbruch varianten
ich will nicht dass die oso anderen
gefährdet werden nur weil leute nicht
bereit sind sich helfen zu lassen die
müssen dann zumindest akzeptiert dass
bestimmte einschränkungen für siege was
ist so ganz klar bei werden noch anders
geht doch nicht um sie selbst ging der
kooperativen dritte wie was wäre ihre
lösung stich verstehe ich finde ich
werde ich verstehe die ich verstehe die
logik nicht ganz denn ich bin hier
aufgefordert worden aber ich habe hier
selbst aufgefordert mich impfen zu
lassen damit ich für ungeimpften oder
von infektiösen keine angst mehr haben
muss bei claas die impfung schützt mich
nicht vor infektionen geschützt mich nur
vor allem schweren verlauf und
möglicherweise einem todesfall so ich
weiß nicht warum geimpfte sich sorgen
machen müssen über ungeimpfte umgehen
müssen sie möglicherweise sorgen darüber
ungeimpfte aber die haben sich selbst
entschieden dass sich nicht impfen
lassen das heißt die tragen das risiko
mein risiko so dankenswerterweise durch
die impfung sei es bisher verstanden
deutlich minimiert worden und wenn ich
die logik von herrn lothar übertragen
wurde auch das allgemeine leben
dann müssten wir uns zwar für alle
verpflichtenden dass wir
grippeschutzimpfungen jedes jahr über
uns ergehen lassen weil wir
logischerweise uns überall sonst auch an
stecken übrigens auch teilweise mit
schweren verläufen mit todesfällen
es gibt noch andere an das
infektionsgeschehen wo wir dann die
überlegung haben müssten
jeder muss sich dann impfen lassen um
andere die sich nicht die nebensaison
nicht haben davor zu bewahren dass sie
erkranken also die logische herr
lauterbach war dohr wir lassen uns alle
impfen weil wir dann ausschließen können
jeweils in aller regel schwerer verläufe
und todesfälle sagt habe ich wenn ich in
die kneipe gehen fünf ungeimpfte schon
gar keine sorge mehr
denn ich bin ja geimpft aber ich wäre
jetzt also erstmal sehr gute sehr sehr
guter grund also einfach unbenommen sehr
guter punkt trotzdem also sehe ich es
anders und wird es auch von den meisten
wissenschaftlern aus gesehen und zwar
auf der grundlage wenn ihr es
meinetwegen in diese kneipe burg also da
gestern war oder genauer gesagt
dagegen hatte wird sich ärgern wenn ich
sage was zeit und bezeichnen aber wenn
da jemand wegen also fünf ungeimpfte
sind die sich gefährden sich ja
gegenseitig und somit ist sozusagen also
achtet ich auch der ungeimpften muss
geschützt werden also ich musste
unbedingt untereinander schützen kann
nicht einfach sagen die sind selbst
schuld aus arbeitet hatte und ich eben
geschrieben aber hallo der tanz auch
nicht verlegt und bringe ich auch nicht
da habe ich noch nicht gehabt doch
dagegen will die entscheidend auch
selbst hast dich nicht sehen jetzt
schützen
wenn ich also würde keinen sinn machen
karriere auch dafür also die also via
die zahl gefahren sind verhindern wir
dass menschen sich gegenseitig gefährden
auch zum beispiel auf der demo die wir
eben gesehen haben das sind ja alles
quere
wenn ich so argumentiert und ich sagen
wenn sie sich das selbst gefährden und
infiziert und sich das ist doch nicht
mein problem
wir machen das ja freiwillig aber wir
haben mit dem mädchen immer geschützt
selbst die die vollkommene rücksichtslos
waren die also von der korona
maßnahmenmix garten haben denen ist in
wirklichkeit egal war auf 552 und somit
wenn ich dann in den usa fünf
ungeschickt und also geh ins habe ist
das haben ein problem das die sich
gegenseitig gefährt ich will ihnen und
demnächst kommt noch das problem mit den
durch die 14 fahrten vorgehen zu
schützen